el dueño de un restaurante quiere
conocer más sobre la procedencia de sus
clientes un día decidió recolectar los
datos de la distancia medida en millas
que recorrían sus clientes para llegar a
su restaurante sus clientes reportaron
las siguientes distancias recorridas
estas de aquí él necesita crear una
gráfica que lo ayude a entender el rango
de las distancias y la mediana de las
distancias que sus clientes viajan qué
clase de gráfica debería realizar bueno
primeramente podríamos analizar que hay
varias gráficas con las cuales podemos
hacer un análisis de estos datos por
ejemplo una línea recta que compare
estos datos con el tiempo sin embargo
pues no nos sirve mucho porque aunque
tengamos la tendencia de estos datos no
tenemos al tiempo además las líneas
miden tendencias de unos datos con
respecto a otros sin embargo aquí
solamente tenemos las distancias que ha
recorrido nuestro cliente por lo tanto
no nos sirve una gráfica de línea
podemos vencer a una gráfica de barras
sin embargo una gráfica de barras
también tenemos que comparar
o más variables podríamos pensar también
una gráfica del pastel sin embargo una
gráfica de pastel analizan porcentajes
que conforman un todo pero aquí no hay
necesidad de sacar porcentajes además
nos hablan de un rango de distancias y
de una mediana de las distancias por lo
tanto la opción correcta va a ser una
gráfica de caracas y bigotes las
gráficas de cajas y bigotes nos muestran
muy claramente el rango y además nos
muestran dividido en cuartos donde está
la mediana y donde se puede encontrar
también cada uno de los cuartos por lo
tanto se me hace la mejor opción lo
primero que nos pide una gráfica de
cajas y bigotes es ordenar todos
nuestros datos de menor a mayor y así
vamos a encontrar fácilmente la mediana
por lo tanto el menor es el uno después
le sigue un dos por aquí y por acá hay
otro dos y si se dan cuenta ya no hay
más dos por lo tanto hemos acabado con
el dos aquí hay un tres por aquí hay un
tres y son los únicos tres es decir
solamente dos personas viajan tres
millas para llegar al restaurante aquí
hay un 4
también por acá hay otro 4 y bueno vamos
a ver ahora qué pasó con el 5
de hecho esperen no hay 5 pero si hay un
1 nos faltó poner este 1 de aquí por lo
tanto vamos a agregarlo al principio un
1 y ahora si no hay 5 espero 66 y ahí al
principio hay un 6 por lo tanto voy a
tacharlo y creo que es el único 6
entonces solamente me queda este 6 y
después 7 es aquí hay un 7 en medio
justo en medio hay un 7 y cerca no hay
un 8 pero solamente hay un 7 también hay
un 8 y nueves no hay fíjense bien no hay
nueves pero si hay un 10 aquí está el 10
y 11 hay solamente uno ya esto es más
fácil 12 no 13 tampoco 14 hay 1 al
principio y un 15 en medio entonces que
hay un 14 y aquí hay un 15 entonces 14
15 y solamente falta acomodar el 20 y el
22 por lo tanto 20 y 22 muy bien ya los
acomodamos de menor a mayor
revisemos a ver si no me equivoqué 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 6 7 muy
bien entonces debo de tener también 17
números abajo vamos a ver 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 muy bien
tengo 17 clientes que contestaron esta
encuesta ahora bien lo primero que puedo
sacar aquí es la mediana la mediana es
aquel valor que está justo en medio y
más aún si tenemos un número impar de
números existe solamente un número que
va a estar a la mitad el que va a estar
nueve unidades es decir va a haber ocho
unidades antes de él y ocho unidades
después de él que es este de aquí aquí
van ocho unidades antes de él y ocho
unidades dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete y ocho después de él es decir ya
tenemos nuestra mediana nuestra mediana
en este caso va a ser seis y bueno para
dejar completamente claro el concepto si
tenemos un par de números entonces van a
existir dos números intermedios la
mediana sería el promedio de esos dos ok
entonces el 6 en este
va a ser nuestra mediana pero para hacer
la gráfica de cajas y bigotes necesito
también los cuartiles los cuartiles son
aquellos números que se encuentran a un
cuarto de todos los números y a tres
cuartos de todos los números es decir es
como si quisiéramos sacar la mediana de
la primera mitad y de la segunda mitad
de los números que nos han quedado en
este caso y es muy fácil porque ya
tenemos la mediana por lo tanto podemos
ver claramente que hay dos grupos de
números los que están en la primera
mitad que son estos y por lo tanto voy a
sacar su mediana como son ocho números
en la primera mitad me voy a fijar en el
quinto lugar y en el cuarto lugar y voy
a sacar su promedio entonces 1 2 3 4 y 5
estos dos números me van a servir para
promediar los y sacar el primer cuartil
2 3 5 y si lo divido entre 2 nueva a dar
2.5 entonces ya tengo el primer cuartil
2.5 va a ser mi primer cuartil porque es
aquel número que ocupa el lugar un
cuarto del total de datos
entonces 2.5 y ahora me voy a fijar en
la segunda mitad por lo tanto voy a
tomar otro color y recuerden que mi
segunda mitad también tiene 8 datos por
lo tanto
voy a fijar en el lugar 13 y en el lugar
14 para sacar mi tercer cuartil 11 14
son mi lugar tres y mi lugar 14 y al
promediar 2 me va a dar mi tercer
cuartel 1114 suman 25 y los dividió
entre 2 me da 12.5 por lo tanto mi
tercer cuarto es 12.5 y ahora si ya
tengo mi primer cuartil mi segundo
cuartil que es la mediana y mi tercer
cuartil que es 12.5 ya tengo toda la
información que necesito para crear la
gráfica de cajas y bigotes entonces
vamos a hacer esa gráfica
por cierto dense cuenta que el haber
sacado los cuartiles y la mediana lo
único que hicimos fue dividir nuestro
total de datos en cuatro partes
representativas y ahora sí vamos a hacer
la gráfica de cajas y bigotes
lo primero que necesito hacer es una
recta numérica que me quede lo más recta
posible es decir que no esté tan hueca
es esta de aquí y voy a suponer que este
es el cero por aquí va a estar el 10
bien este de aquí va a ser mi 10 y por
lo tanto por acá va a estar el 20 si de
aquí acá hay 10 por lo tanto aquí hay 5
y aquí va a ser el 15 voy a ponerlo más
ordenado aquí es el 15 muy bien ahora lo
primero que voy a poner en esta recta
numérica es mi rango por lo tanto me voy
a fijar en el valor más chico de todos
mis datos que es 1 y el 1 se encuentra
más o menos por aquí por aquí debe estar
el 1 muy bien y me voy a fijar en el
valor más grande de todos mis datos que
ver que es 22 y está como por acá voy a
etiquetar a estos dos valores para no
perdernos en esta gráfica el valor más
pequeño es el 1 y el valor más grande de
todos mis datos es el 22 los siguientes
que voy a hacer es dibujar la caja para
dibujar la caja me voy a aplicar en el
primer cuartil y en mi tercer cuartil mi
primer cuartil es 2.5 y ahí es donde va
a iniciar mi caja entonces vamos a
ponerlo 2.5 está justo aquí y aquí es
donde inicia mi caja y ahora me voy a
fijar en mi tercer cuartil que es 12.5 y
ahí es donde va a finalizar mi caja
entonces voy a cambiar al color azul y
aquí está 12.5
tanto ya tengo mi inicio y el final de
mi caja ahora falta de dibujarlas voy a
cambiar el color amarillo que es un
color neutro en este momento y voy a
poner toda mi caja y lo que nos muestra
la caja es donde se encuentra la mitad
central de nuestros datos ahora voy a
dibujar los bigotes este va a ser mi
primer bigote de donde acaba la caja
hasta donde está el valor final y mi
otro bigote que empieza de la caja y
llega hasta el valor más pequeño de
todos mis datos los bigotes lo que me
piden es en donde se encuentran todos
los demás datos de este problema ahora
bien me voy a aplicar en la mediana que
no la he puesto y mi mediana está en el
6 entonces es justo esta de clic esta va
a ser mi mediana y ya tengo mi gráfica
de cajas y bigotes y bueno esta gráfica
qué información me da lo primero que me
dice es donde se encuentran y mediana y
mediana se encuentra en el 6 lo segundo
que me dice es donde se encuentra la
mitad central de todos mis datos que se
encuentra entre el 2.5 y se encuentra
entre el 12.5 y después lo que me dice
es donde se encuentran todos los datos
los datos se encuentran entre los
bigotes es decir entre el valor más
pequeño
no lo voy a poner aquí entre el valor
más grande que era el 22 es este de aquí
22 y no sólo eso aún hay más podemos
poner las partes de nuestros datos
también en nuestra gráfica por ejemplo
todos estos datos de aquí son mi primer
bigote entonces todos estos datos de
aquí corresponden a este bigote de aquí
ahora bien todos los demás datos estos
que siguen aquí son mi primera parte de
mi caja entonces todos los demás datos
lo voy a poner con otro color estos
datos de aquí corresponden a mi primer
caja después se encuentra mi mediana y
después de mi mediana corresponden a
estos datos que siguen aquí que son mi
segunda parte de la caja hasta este dato
lo voy a colorear de color azul estos de
aquí y para finalizar mi segundo bigote
correspondería a estos últimos datos que
tengo en mi problema estos de aquí son
todos estos datos que yo tengo acá que
es mi segundo bigote muy bien ok y en
resumidas cuentas que hicimos lo primero
que hicimos fue ordenar los números de
menor a mayor después sacamos la mediana
y después sacamos la mediana de las dos
partes
quedaban de la primera parte sacamos su
mediana y de la segunda parte sacamos su
mediana para encontrar así los cuartiles
este procedimiento es típico para sacar
la gráfica de cajas bigotes ahora que lo
pienso muchas personalmente una la
mediana para calcular los dos cuarteles
sin embargo el procedimiento que realice
en este vídeo es el más común para
encontrar la gráfica de cajas y bigotes